ich ein Handwerker bin liebe ich meine
Arbeit aber zurzeit ist es so dass es
sich wieder finanziell auszahlt und auch
emotional ist es manchmal sehr schwierig
Personalkosten sind den letzten 4er
Jahren explodiert möchte ich sagen aber
auch Rohstoffkosten z.B beisp Kilo
Zucker hat vor 4 Jahren noch 38 Cent
gekostet jetzt kostet 1,10 € und für
viele anderen Kollegen ist noch teurer
Energiekosten natürlich
2020 Vergleich zu 22 haben wir 700.000 €
mehr Energiekosten gehabt ich persönlich
habe nicht den Eindruck dass die
politisch Handelnden Person überhaupt
ich sag mal so ansatzweise verstehen was
da passiert es gibt viel
Lippenbekenntnisse ja wir haben das
verstanden und so weiter aber wir als
Unternehmen brauchen verlässliche
Rahmenbedingung und die bietet die
derzeit die Politik
[Musik]
nicht